there's days where I feel like I know it
all and then I wake up the next morning
and I'm like wait none of that makes
sense and then later I'll feel like oh
wait it's all clicking and then it's not
seven seasons later and we're still
keeping up with the lodges
all those for Veronica
never cross a lodge as Camila Mendes
celebrates riverdale's final season by
poking fun at the show's wild plot lines
it's a beautiful thing the premiere
episode of the seventh and final season
of the hit CW Show aired Wednesday and
Camila marked the occasion on Tick Tock
lip syncing this clip of Kim Kardashian
on Keeping Up with the Kardashians
there's days where I feel like I know it
all and then I wake up the next morning
and I'm like wait none of that makes
sense and then later I'll feel like oh
wait it's all clicking and then it's not
Camila calls the clip keeping up with
the plot of Riverdale and in the caption
she sarcastically Clips final season
premieres tonight and yes our show is
still going get over it I'm so excited
in the season 7 premiere Veronica Archie
Betty Jughead and the rest of the crew
travel back in time to the 1950s
damn even in 1955 Veronica Lodge knew
how to make an entrance Camila and her
co-stars Lily Reinhardt Madeline petch
and Vanessa Morgan all shared BTS video
which included lots of retro fashion and
a lot of blood
[Music]
Madeline posted this Montage which she
calls a small taste of the Ruckus on set
I work with my best friends and that's
rare back in December Lily admitted she
shed a few tears while wrapping up the
final season I'm thankful for Riverdale
for my fans for my dear Betty and for
the family I've made through this
experience so Riverdale the final season
when you just went back to work stepping
on set did it feel different than all
the times before it does it does it has
a Bittersweet feeling to it and I think
I'm kind of just trying to approach this
season with uh not taking anything for
granted really trying to be present
trying to enjoy my co-stars so it is
it's different for me at least
we've still got plenty of episodes to
get through till we reach the series
finale so until then we'll try to keep
up there's days where I feel like I know
it all and then I wake up the next
morning and I'm like wait none of that
makes sense
[Music]
thank you